well today's announcements were billed
as the government's plan to achieve
greater energy Independence and the UN
the United Nations of course the
International Energy agency and the
climate change committee here in the UK
have all said that the way to do this is
to get off gas move to more Renewables
and reduce our gas demand in the first
place through things like insulating our
homes however the government's plan
doesn't seem to have any new
announcements on these sorts of things
there's some nods towards more offshore
wind and solar power but it falls short
of what the Renewables industry were
calling for in order to boost that
industry and invest into the UK and
there's definitely no new money for
insulation so that's a bit of a blow
towards the UK's energy security and
it's potentially at odds with what the
experts both International and in the UK
are saying is needed to achieve energy
Independence 80 of us use gas more or
less to heat our homes what do we do how
do we start to change that absolutely so
we're very reliant on gas for our
Heating and for some of our power
generation as well so that has left us
uniquely exposed to high gas prices
which everyone knows are driving but the
cost of living crisis and household Bill
increases now there are solutions that
are already taking place in Europe
there's over 20 million heat pumps
installed which run on electricity
instead and they can help to save people
money in the long run as electricity
gets cheaper with more Renewables on the
system however the government's plans
towards heat pumps are a bit lackluster
today they've confirmed they're going to
extend an existing scheme for another
three years but there's no real clue
about how much more ambitious this is
going to be if at all so again we've got
mixed messages about what the
government's plan actually is towards
decarbonizing our heating we
um the government's been told that it
must move to Net Zero by 20 within the
next 10 years to make any difference how
far away are we from that well the
recent report by the intergovernmental
panel on climate change has actually
said that if we don't reach net zero
emissions climate change will not be
halted and its impacts will worsen
including here in the UK we've seen heat
waves we've seen droughts we've seen
flooding these things are going to get
worse unless we reach Net Zero and like
you say the government's been told that
it needs to up not only its Ambitions
but also its delivery plan and today's
release Net Zero strategy which is an
update after they were taken to court
over it not being substantial enough and
we're still unclear about how much
further that's going to go but actually
the government do have a lot of ground
to make up for what's the one thing that
people can do watching from home this
morning just to make a difference well
the thing that will really make a
difference not only to energy security
but also to household bills which
everybody is clearly worried about at
the moment is insulating our homes now
the government has re-announced today
plans it's already made so there's no
new money there but if you can afford it
you know going to bnq getting some Loft
insulation rolling that out looking into
cavity wall insulation and also looking
at what you're going to do when your gas
boiler does eventually break and those
are the sorts of things that can help
however lots of fuel poverty groups
campaigners are all saying that there
needs to be more government support
because people simply can't afford to do
these things on their own when you
boiler when your gas boil I'm sure this
is a question lots of people will be
wondering when you get a spoiler you
know you do want to replace it do you
have to replace all the pipes as well no
so when um it comes to decarbonizing
heating the solution that's thought to
be in the majority of the future
Solutions is heat pumps and they work on
electricity so you wouldn't need to
install kind of new cables or anything
like that because you have electricity
in your home already but you would need
to cap off your existing gas supply and
heat pumps at the moment you can get a
government grant for about five grand or
six grand if it's a certain type of heat
pump which helps to reduce the price but
there's also a bit of a distortion in
the market where gas is artificially
higher than sorry electricity is
artificially higher than gas because of
levees that are put on electricity the
government said it wants to look at
these and rebalance them between gas and
electricity but it's been a bit slow it
was first told to do this four years ago
and it's only during the gas crisis of
the thought they might actually go on
with it we we did speak to a chap though
who said that he wanted to take his heat
pump out because it's actually costing
him more for his power now his energy
now that he's got one that can be an
unfortunate
um result of if you don't have very good
insulation in your home
um it means that all of the heat that
you do produce from your gas boiler or
your heat pump is simply leaking out of
the walls and the roofs and it might be
that his fabric of the building is not
quite ready for a heat pump it's very
important to do insulation first so that
your house is ready for a heat pump and
it makes sense as well because whatever
heating system you have insulating your
home will reduce the amount of heat that
you need to buy